good morning Hank it's Wednesday January
30th and today's video comes to you in
one part part one I am NOT a
pornographer Hank you may remember that
almost three years ago my first novel
Looking for Alaska was published I just
found out that Looking for Alaska is
about to be taught to 11th grade English
students at Depew high school outside of
Buffalo New York
Alaska is taught in a lot of English
classes around the country but it's
still pretty awesome to hear that
someone is going to like teach your book
in a regular English class and people
are going to read it closely and think
hard about it so here's what happened
because there are a few scenes in
Looking for Alaska that some people find
controversial the Depew high school
administrators and English teachers got
together and they wrote a letter saying
we're going to teach this book we think
it's pretty good if you're okay with
your kid being taught this book please
sign this permission slip otherwise the
kid will read some other book so parents
who are cool with their kids reading
Looking for Alaska get to have their
kids are looking for Alaska and parents
who aren't cool with it get to have
their kids read some other book but
there were a few people who weren't
happy with this solution these people
didn't actually have kids who were in
the 11th grade but no matter they think
that my book is pornographic and that it
will cause immoral thoughts and actions
in children these people believe that no
one should be allowed to read the book
even those people whose parents sign the
permission slip
now Hank it's no secret that I like for
things to be about me but this really
isn't still I have to tell you that when
you're told that the novel that you
wrote for teenagers is pornography you
start to feel a little bit mad I don't
know exactly what it is that bothers me
about that characterization I mean it's
not the ography I wouldn't mind if
someone was like we must get this book
out of our classrooms it's full of
geography or no teenager should ever
have to read this disgusting work of
lexicography no Hank it's not the
ography that bothers me it's the porn
pornography is designed to titillate
Hank I don't think there's a single
halfway normal person in the world who
would find a single thing in my book in
any way arousing there is one very frank
sex scene it is awkward unfund
disastrous and wholly unerotic Hank the
whole reason that scene in question
exists in Looking for Alaska is because
I wanted to draw a contrast between that
scene when there's a lot of physical
intimacy but it's ultimately very
emotionally
empty and the scene that immediately
follows it when there's not a serious
physical interaction but there's this
intense emotional connection the
argument here is that physical intimacy
can never stand in for emotional
closeness and that when teenagers
attempt to conflate these ideas it
inevitably fails Hank it doesn't take a
deeply critical understanding of
literature to realize that Looking for
Alaska is arguing against vapid physical
interactions not for them now Hank some
people are going to say that kids don't
have the critical sophistication when
they're reading to understand that and I
have a message for those people shut up
and stop condescending to teenagers do
you seriously think that teenagers
aren't able to read critically when they
read George Orwell's Animal Farm do they
head out to the pig farms to kill all
the pigs because they're about to become
communist autocrats when they read Huck
Finn did they think that Huck should
turn Jim in because the demented
conscience of the community says so when
they read Waiting for Godot do they
think it's cool to just sit around and
do nothing well probably they do
actually that one doesn't really work
toward my point
now obviously Hank I don't think that a
few parents should get to decide what
the kids of other parents read in school
those parents are qualified to sign or
not sign that permission slip as they
see fit and to speak frankly Hank it
also pisses me off when small groups of
well organized would be book banners try
to take over America's public school
systems now fortunately in Depew there
are a lot of teachers and school
administrators and school board members
who are standing up for my book and for
the right of teachers to teach it and
for the right of parents to choose to
have it taught to their kids but Hank
sometimes these people who make stands
for intellectual freedom can feel like
they're going it alone which is why I'd
like to ask from the bottom of my heart
that any nerdfighters who live in or
around Depew go to the school board
meeting on February 5th info in the
sidebar also I've written a letter in
defense of the teachers who'd like to
teach my book if you'd like to write a
letter send it to sparks fly up at
gmail.com and I'll be sure to forward it
on Hank thanks to you and all the
nerdfighters in advance for your emails